what I'd like to talk about is a little
more general and that is the context for
PEPFAR and development in general and
the future in that regard where we came
from and and some opportunities going
forward in context as Mike mentioned
PEPFAR it's actually not only the
largest international health initiative
in history in US history it's the
largest in history period and at 19
billion dollars which doesn't sound like
a lot of money except when you consider
when we started the annual appropriation
was in the 500 million dollar range so
it's huge by development standards I'm
told I'm not sure if this is true but
I'm told that is the single largest
discretionary program in the United
States government including domestic
programs so it's a very large program
but it doesn't stand alone and it
actually was part of something that
President Bush called a new Aaron
development and I think that's important
because there was an eye there were
ideas behind it and I was part of a
larger picture and the reason I want to
talk about that is because I think it's
important to look to the future to think
about where it came from and the ideas
behind it were very important and formed
a new framework a new framework for how
we looked at development it changed the
old approach which was donors and
recipients a very paternalistic approach
and said that that's the wrong approach
that's the wrong framework for looking
at development that would really mean
matters is country leadership what's
commonly called country ownership but
that means countries themselves
governments and the people of the
country's direct own manage and lead
their own programs and I think that's a
critical change in order for countries
to do that there has to be good
governance you have to have a result
based approach you can't achieve the
countries can achieve what they want to
achieve without good governance and
without a results based approach all
sectors need to be engaged for a long
time development was thought of it only
as a government activity but if you
don't have the non-governmental sector
the communities the community
organizations the people on the ground
faith community based organizations on
the private sector engage basically feed
on people owning their lives you're not
going to tackle development problems and
the last principle that economic growth
is key development programs are stopgaps
as countries grow economically but it's
important stop gap to save lives along
the way this new approach which seems
like a lot of common sense was not the
way we did development before in fact
the New York Times called a
philosophical revolution which I don't
think is actually an overstatement it
was a fundamentally different approach
and it changed the conversation it
changed the conversation about
development not only in the United
States but globally now I think an
important piece of that that is pet bhar
specific is that if in development we're
going to ask for good governance abroad
we need good governance at home and we
needed a much better management approach
to how the US government did development
I think this is relevant from
multilaterals as well when PEPFAR
started what we inherited and saw across
u.s. u.s. government programs in HIV
which was true and development is a very
siloed very fragmented approach and that
doesn't get you very far what it gets
you a lot of turf wars we were actually
to a point where in countries US
government people employed by all of us
all of us taxpayers from USAID from
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention from Department of Defense
sometimes department of labor peace
corps we're all doing HIV programs but
they frequently didn't know each other
literally I was in countries where they
did not know each other as people they
didn't have their phone numbers they had
absolutely no idea what programs they
were working on individually so CDC had
me running a program USAID sometimes in
the same district and they wouldn't know
what was happening with another program
run by the US government and the
ambassador's were completely out of the
loop because the agencies didn't want
anyone to know what they were doing
because that's how they protected their
ownership that is not a way to approach
hiv/aids it is not a way to approach
development and that is something that
was repeated across the US government so
again if we were going to ask
used to practice good governance it's
kind of incumbent on us to at practice
good governance and so what PEPFAR did
we say that's not a very good approach
and that we needed to bring everyone
together under one strategic vision in a
common framework that limited overlap
and that had everyone going in the same
direction and we hope that direction was
to support governments and countries to
achieve their goals and development and
in HIV in specific now that shift
required a lot of bureaucratic maneuvers
which I'm happy to talk about in the
question period if you all want to talk
about it wasn't easy it's nowhere near
done but what it also required was
leadership leadership in global health
and Mike asked me to talk a little bit
about that and a new approach to
leadership part of that leadership was
accepting that we weren't supposed to be
in control an important part of
leadership is sometimes seating
responsibility and it is a very
important step for us to say we are not
donors and recipients we are equal
partners and that what people in other
countries did or was actually more
important and that we are indeed the
junior partner when we're dealing with
development that we are actually
supporting them not not not they are
doing what we asked them to do it's a
leadership style that I know most people
in this room probably don't want to
believe but wasn't here President Bush
he actually had that view and that
leadership style the view actually that
we needed to get country ownership very
much emanated from his belief and from
our of our beliefs that development is
not about helping poor uneducated people
that it is simply a life circumstance
where you live and that development is
not because we are the whining nights
coming to help people or save them we're
coming to support extraordinary human
beings who if given the chance will take
their lives and control and tackle their
problems and so a big part of global
leadership and health which mike asked
me to talk about is to accept that
difference that change in dynamic
another important part of the leadership
is to care about the issue this is a
deeply personal issue for a lot of
people who worked
from President Bush to the people on the
ground people cared enough to change the
bureaucracy to overcome bureaucratic
obstacles because they cared about the
people on the ground it also meant
believing in people as I mentioned to
not only ship that dynamic of who's in
charge but to actually make yourself
unimportant that's a really important
thing in global leadership on hiv/aids
but I think in development in general
and in management in general that a good
leader actually makes themselves
unimportant because you empower the
people around you to take charge another
and part of this global leadership shift
was in HIV and development was holding
high standards holding people to high
standards the president of Kagame of
Rwanda was talking about PEPFAR and
talked about this and said one of the
most remarkable things it was for the
first time people were holding them to a
high standard not in a paternalistic way
but in believing in them enough to say
we believe you can achieve this and as
he said when you hold people to high
standards they actually will step up if
you presume people can't achieve
anything they're not going to meet
anything they're not going to feel like
they need to achieve anything and that
is a fundamental piece of this new
leadership the last piece I think was
getting the best out of people and that
had to do with all of the above by
acknowledging that we were the junior
partner that we were there to support by
believing in people by believing in so
much that we would hold them to high
standards you got the most out of people
and that was leadership that was
leadership from individuals and it was
leadership from a government the United
States government and was leadership
from the people in the countries from
presidents on down dambisa moyo I'm sure
some of you have seen her book dead aid
is basically a decade old it argues
basically that most of the leaders in
Africa a bunch of corrupt people are
just trying to steal from their people
there's still some of that there's still
some of that in this country but by and
large there's been a huge shift in the
leadership in the people in Africa from
presidents to ministers of health within
the ministries and on the ground people
running NGOs who are trying to take and
control their lives if we give them the
support and so that leadership component
of
Global Health from president down to
people on the ground had a major impact
on our approach to good governance and
why PEPFAR succeeded so what are the
results how did things actually turn out
well there are a couple things in
general I want to talk about and then
specifically one is and I think this may
be one of the most important legacies of
PEPFAR zits the first-ever effort in
development to deal with a chronic
disease that's a rather remarkable
statement and some of that has to do
with that global global leadership
literally seven years ago when the UN
General Assembly was arguing about
Millennium Development Goals many
countries including the United States
argued against treatment goal a
treatment goal and some of that was
money but a lot of it was people
actually thought that people in
developing countries were incapable of
managing chronic health care delivery
system people made some pretty
outrageous statement about watches and
telling time and a lot of pretty other
other terrible things but it really was
the first time we attacked a chronic
disease and believed in people to to
deal with the chronic disease and that
is going to have huge impacts in how we
deal with global health so I think
that's an important success and legacy
of the program which is very much
related to that philosophical revolution
and how we approach things but in
addition to that general approach of
changing a perception of development and
a culture around development we also had
very specific goals related to HIV which
were prevention treatment and care and
it was also the first initiative that
said you can't do one without the other
that moved past the debates of should we
do prevention or treatment no one ever
talked about care which was a great
tragedy because you can't do effective
treatment or prevention without care and
all these orphans are dying with no
education and no food but very few
people we're talking about that was just
treatment or prevention is the first
initiative to say you can't do one
without the other and I'm afraid today
we're losing that we're getting back to
treatment or prevention again cares
getting lost but we had very specific
goals two million people supported for
treatment seven million infections of
Verdun ten million and care within
several months ahead of schedule
president bush announced that we achieve
the treatment goal supported treatment
for more than 2.1 million people up from
zero
five years earlier Stanford University
did a study that can that demonstrated
that that led to a million lives saved
in just the first three years millions
of lives have been saved as a result of
the treatment goal being met today four
million people in the developing world
are in treatment but three million of
them are supported from the American
people rather dramatic from zero
literally from zero and everyone saying
you couldn't do treatment to having four
million people in treatment just a few
years later prevention it's too early to
tell the goal was actually 2010 goal but
all the trends are going in the right
direction and this is a point people
really aren't paying attention to
treatment is something you can measure
rapidly and we did measure rapidly
because it's relatively easy to measure
you can go to a clinic and tell many
people in treatment prevention takes
years because you're doing demographic
health surveys every five years the
recent results are rather breathtaking
South Africa just reported that in the
last three years there was a forty to
sixty percent reduction forty to sixty
percent reduction in every category of
15 to 24 year olds unbelievable we had
never seen anything other than a
straight up pattern in South Africa
before the importance about 4 15 to 24
year olds it's an incidence marker
because those are new people coming into
the infection because they're getting
outside of 25 year olds in the course of
a demographic health survey we don't
have good incident markers but it's as
good as we're going to get it may be
reported a fifty percent reduction in
prevalence among 15 to 24 year olds
fifty percent reduction fascinating they
didn't see much of a reduction above 24
year olds we've seen thirty-three
percent reductions in Kenya twenty-five
percent reduction in Botswana recently
twenty-five percent reduction at least
in Zimbabwe huge reductions in HIV rates
doesn't mean we done a long way to go
we've got a very long way to go but it's
a very good trend in the right direction
on care in the goal was met more than 10
million people and Karen cleaning four
million orphans and vulnerable children
so I think the results both in terms of
changing the approach but also in terms
of the actual results were rather
remarkable but there are a couple of
important issues and challenges not only
deal with a couple of them the first is
country ownership itself if we're honest
with ourselves there was a real struggle
early on with country ownership some of
that is the way the program was
announced it was announced picking
countries there were trade-offs to the
way that was done it was the only way
would work in the state of the union
address but there's also part of the
culture of our development structure
that tilts towards we own things and
don't want to give them up I've actually
sat in rooms with junior Foreign Service
officers lecturing ministers of health
about how they should run their programs
in their country that's an intrinsic
inherent part of our development
infrastructure and we didn't overcome it
we still very much live in that but we
understood that and towards the end of
the program we developed what were
called partnership frameworks where we
expected countries and the United States
to sit down together to think about in
five years where they wanted to go and
where we wanted to go together where we
wanted to support them I think a
demonstration of how far we have to go
it's a great effort how far we have to
go is the night before one of these
partnership frameworks was due the
deputy chief of mission from a country
called and asked me it was okay if he
submitted without checking with the
Minister of Health that's not country
ownership and I think it's a
demonstration of how far we have to go
even when we try to get there the fact
that the deputy chief of mission was
surprised when I told him that he
couldn't submit it until he got the
support of the Minister of Health was
equally telling a second huge challenge
is integration of programs I don't mean
PEPFAR paying for everything that's not
the way any structure should work one of
the biggest flaws and development is
thinking every project should solve
every problem which usually means we
don't do anything but it does there is a
challenge to integrate HIV services
can't stand alone maternal child health
is linked to it water is linked to it
family planning is linked to it say
nutrition is linked to it health systems
and building health structures are
linked to it our development structures
are not built for
integration let me give you a couple of
frightening examples a team the team in
Haiti the PEPFAR team in Haiti we wanted
to support food and nutrition for
orphans and for pregnant women important
part of HIV programs rather than PEPFAR
starting a whole new granting process
for food the haiti team came up with a
great idea we would just give money to
the food for Peace program of USAID and
they would manage the program
effectively for us report back to us but
we wouldn't have to set up new
structures the procurement officer said
we couldn't do that that that was not
allowed by the rules we had to do
separate announcements for food
nutrition programs outside of the food
for Peace program totally untrue legally
by the way but that's the nature of how
siloed our programs are when the when
the malaria program started we had a
huge supply chain management system
which we had just funded nine
organizations including two in Africa
that were built to supply to ensure no
stock out of drugs with regional medical
center with regional supply centers in
three parts of Africa that avoided any
significant stock outs that supply
system included bed nets and a CTS
because pregnant women and young kids
who are hiv-positive particularly
susceptible to malaria so we felt we
needed to supply those products when the
president's malaria initiative started
we went to them and said use our
infrastructure use the supply chain
management system that we have you'll
have to pay a little bit incrementally
to increase it but use the system the
lawyers wouldn't let us they issued a
separate announcement they basically
hired the exact same people so now we
have the same people doing to supply
systems getting double paid and
countries have to deal with an HIV
supply system and a malaria supply
system from the US government now these
are not the decisions of individual
people who are trying to do the right
thing the idea in Haiti came from
development officers our development
people are among the most dedicated
talented people you will come across but
the structure and culture of our
development organizations does not lend
itself to integration that's not unique
to the bilateral system the UN system is
no different everything is siloed and
separated and what happens unfortunately
as people get more and more removed from
the country those silos lead to
fours and people make decisions in
Washington or in Geneva that actually
kill people without thinking about that
all that is thought about is how much
money does this organization control our
lines of procurement respected not how
many lives could be saved if we did it a
different way and that's a big problem
and so full country ownership and
integration are two big challenges not
only for PEPFAR but how the US
government and actually multilaterally
and multi nationally and in particular
the UN systems we do development so
looking to the future what are some
possibilities what are some ways out of
this you know as president bush said
with PEPFAR this it was a good start a
lot of people say it's a huge success I
personally believe that but it's a start
it's only a start to try to unravel 50
years of development based in
post-colonial guilt and cold and the
cold war and for siloed separated
systems so we have a couple of options
going forward one is to break apart and
remake the US government development
infrastructure that is focused on that
those principles of the New araen
development focused on fully focused on
country ownership good governance
results base and all sectors being
engaged that requires a huge cultural
and structural shift it requires
remaking human resource procurement all
the systems that no one wants to talk
about when they talk about development
reform but that's where the heart of it
is that's where bad decisions get made
that's where non integration occurs no
doubt we have to do that we cannot
tolerate any longer our current approach
to development within the US government
but that's going to take a lot of time
huge bureaucratic hurdles we're fighting
upstream against 50 years of laws
regulations practice policy culture and
structure but there's no question we
need to undertake that battle and
Congress is looking to reform what they
call foreign assistance would be nice if
we got rid of the term assistance all
together because it implies that
donor-recipient paternalistic approach
regardless we have some opportunity
and we ought to do that but we also have
another option which is radical change
while we are fixing our own development
structure look to new architectures and
new approaches that could radically
change PEPFAR is not that PEPFAR was the
beginning it was a transit transit
student transitionary phase to save a
lot of lives it could be transformed for
through partnership compacts it could be
transformed as we look to more
integrated services to fill some of
these gaps and roles but that's not what
it was designed for the Millennium
Challenge corporation a very innovative
structure that was also creating the
last administration and the Global Fund
to fight AIDS tuberculosis and malaria
are probably the two institutions that
in original design and by architecture
our best designed to move forward in a
new era and development based on those
principles and so another option as
we're building the u.s. architecture are
rebuilding the u.s. architecture is to
look at those two as opportunities and
perhaps the greatest opportunity is the
Global Fund because it's the right thing
to do it's multilateral it has all
stakeholders engaged and it meets those
principles although institutionally it
has some things to work out it's
probably the right structure and my own
view is that we should expand it to a
global fund for health so that there's
one funding source for an integrated
approach across all the health related
development goals and that if you have
one funding stream you then are able to
support countries for a country owned
approach that would integrate programs
without having the pre-existing silos
you have the chance to do something new
you have the chance to form and frame
something that isn't retrofitting it's
somewhat the same system as I was coming
up on reason why coming up on the train
today I lost calls about seven times on
the eastern seaboard of the United
States but if you go to the most rural
remote area in Africa you'll get great
cell phone service they didn't have to
retrofit they could start new we could
do the same with development we can look
for the new architecture the new
approach that doesn't require all
painful retrofitting and the Global Fund
and the Millennium Challenge corporation
offer that opportunity but we need to be
merit-based if the Global Fund or the
Millennium Challenge corporation stray
from those principles of new Arab
development which they can do there are
also bureaucratic institutions or if
existing institutions like the US
government bilateral programs or PEPFAR
evolved as they need to to better fit
those principles then let's go with that
let's go with whatever meets those
principles of a new air and development
not prejudge what the best is a little
competition is a very healthy thing a
little competition between CDC and USAID
and DOD is one of the reasons we
succeeded in PEPFAR so let's create the
principles and see who gets there let's
hold out a merit-based approach and
let's move there at the moment we
probably need both PEPFAR PMI and the
Global Fund as we're scaling up but for
the future let's find out what works
best and invest in that and I don't know
which one will be provided money down
i'd say the Global Fund on the MCC so
I'm actually going to end there because
i think i mostly want to have a
conversation with you but i do think we
are at a unique moment in history we are
at a time when people recognize the harm
both to our moral character and to our
security and strategic interests of a
lack of development we have an
opportunity with a new generation of
leaders both in this country globally
I'm talking about from the last ten
years going forward and in country most
importantly we have opportunity we can
take the easy way out we can take the
damn be so moyo kill aid we can take the
approach of partial and imperfect
reforms that won't get us to where we
need to be or we can say let's do
something radical and let's focus on
saving lives and lifting up lives let's
focus on development and getting there
and we have that opportunity today so I
look forward to talking with you more
and to hear your thoughts and your
questions and comments